just show you some pictures coming into
Us from Southern Ukraine and President
Vladimir zielinski has visited regions
devastated by the flooding after about a
dam rather was blown up in
russian-controlled territory this is
near kerson which has been taken by the
Russians this is a video that was posted
from the telegram messaging app and you
can see President zielinski there
um talking to people troops on the
ground trying to organize rescues and he
said the immediate priority was rescuing
stranded people as well as getting food
and water to the region There's real
concern about disease with those Rising
flood waters there as well as access to
food as well of course agricultural land
also covered by the flood so real
concerns about the future as well as
well as the immediate impact on people
living in that area so you can see
President Vladimir zelensky visiting the
regions affected this morning